now let's go to Florida where cases are
up more than a hundred and forty percent
since the state reopened or began
reopening rather on May 18th it has now
exceeded five thousand new infections
for two days in a row Manuel Bojorquez
has more on the surge there across
Florida long lines pushed Cove at 19
testing centers to capacity Thursday the
number of younger people infected is
growing and look they are less at risk
there's no doubt about it they obviously
want to be out there and be very be more
social but governor Ron de Santos warns
they could threaten Florida's older
population it's just important for folks
in the upper age groups to just
understand that that's out there
continue to take the proper steps and
maintain the appropriate social distance
Florida reopened last month without a
statewide Basques mandate but last night
Miami became the latest city to require
them in public violators could face
fines miami-dade County now accounts for
a quarter of all the state's infections
based on the latest batch of testing
more than 10 percent of people tested in
the county are positive
[Music]
in Miami Beach code enforcement officers
are making sure businesses are following
new guidelines as the cases in Florida
increase does your job have a new sense
of urgency yes it does we basically have
to make sure that more businesses are in
compliance Governor De Santis says as of
now there are no plans for the state to
enter the next phase of reopening at
this testing center along Miami Beach
some people waited more than four hours
for a test yesterday this morning a line
of cars is already formed on the other
side the city said it will increase its
testing capacity today to try to meet
that demand
Tony Gael all right Thank You Manuel